في صحيفه الاندبندنت حديث عن تصدعات واضحه
بين اسرائيل وحليفتها الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا تنعكس في تصريحات المسؤولين
بشان اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه تاتي
التصدعات في وقت تعلو فيه اصوات الاف
الاسرائيليين المطالبين بتحرير رهاء
واجراء انتخابات جديده ووسط انقسامات
واضحه داخل مجلس الحرب حول مستقبل الصراع
وخطط ما بعد الحرب في
غزه في صحيفه الجارديان مقال يست عد نجاح
محاولات القضاء على حماس وقادتها في غزه
بل يتوقع ان تؤدي خطط اسرائيل بشان مستقبل
القطاع الى استمرار نشاطها الذي قد يتحول
الى ساحات اخرى كانت حماس تتجنبها
وبالتالي فان خطرها لن يتراجع وهذا يقود
الى ان الحل الاكثر واقعيه هو التفكير في
كيفيه دمج حماس ضمن السلطه التي تحكم غزه
بعد الحرب بدلا من التفكير في
استئصالها افتتاحيتها ارتس را ان الحل
الوحيد للصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني هو
الدفع نحو اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه وابعاد
نتنياهو تقول الصحيفه ان احسن ما فعله
بايدن هو اعاده حل الدولتين الى الاجنده
الدبلوماسيه وفي هذه المرحله يتعين على
ادارته ان تدرك ان نتنياهو لن يلتزم باي
وعد يطلقه وعلى الاسرائيليين التخلي عم من
يعرض مستقبل اسرائيل للخطر في مجله
ايكونوميست نقرا ان الهجمات والاغتيالات
تجعل الولايات المتحده وايران اقرب الى
الحرب تروي المجله بعض الاحداث المتسارعه
وترى فيها علامه على ان منع توسع الحرب
انطلاقا من غزه كما يريد بايدن بات اكثر
صعوبه تتوقع المجله ضغوطا متزايد على
بايدن للرد على ايران ووكلائها بالشرق
الاوسط حتى لا تبدو امريكا ضعيفه فهو اذا
يخاطر بدخول حرب جديده في عام
الانتخابات نشرت صحيفه الاموم تحقيق مطولا
جاء فيه ان الولايات المتحده ومعها قوى
اخرى تدفع اليوم ثمن غفلتها عن تنام قدرات
الحوثييين ليتحول اليوم الى لاعبين فاعلين
في الصراع بالشرق الاوسط وكتبت لوموند ان
لا احد كان يتوقع تهديدا ياتي من اليمن
الذي انهكته الازمات المتعاقبه وما يزيد
من تهديد التنظيم هو كونه لا يزال مجهولا
الى حد
[موسيقى]
كبير